اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل تسعه عسكريين
بينهم خمسه ضباط خلال معارك في غزه خلال
الساعات ال 24 الماضيه جنوبيه ووسط قطاع
غزه وبذلك يرتفع عدد القتلى العسكريين
المعلن عنهم الى
191 منذ بدء العمليه البريه والعدد
الاجمالي الى
54 منذ عمليه طوفان الاقصى وقالت هيئه
البث الاسرائيليه ان سته من العسكريين
قتلوا في تفجير شاحنه تحمل ذخائر كانت
مخصصه لتدمير الانفاق في غزه وقال موقع
ولا العبدري ان تفجير اسفر عن اصابه 30
جنديا وضابطا وقالت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه
ان تحقيقا اوليا للجيش اكد ان تفجير شاحنه
الذخائر بالبريج سببه اطلاق نار من دبابه
اسرائيليه كما ذكرت اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان خمسه عسكريين قتلوا في
تفجير عبوه ناسفه في وسط قطاع
غزه